washing my face
Black foundation
If you don't do black, your eyes might look more responding
Always do black
I'm at on sleeping mode
We are still sleeping
Jjajaja
Play
Playing
What is this?
Let's see
Thanks
Hairs
Ok
It's too much
It's dirty
I got a fan mail
I'm so glad that I got to see you
I've been waiting for you
I love you
I miss you
Hello, hello
Welcome
Happy Mother's Day
Thank you all for being with us today
My name is Kat, my pronouns are she and her
I want to extend a special welcome
to all of you who are new
or just here for the first time in a long time
I'm so glad that you're with us tonight
and that you've chosen to join us
Every year we take two Sundays off
to give our volunteers a little break
The Sunday after Christmas
and Memorial Day
which of course is coming up on Sunday, May 25th
So mark your calendars and don't show up on Sunday, May 25th
or you'll be here alone
You can go play on the playground
We are partnering with the Texas Ramp Project
to build wheelchair ramps for those in need
In order to do that, we would like to get a better idea
of how many people may be interested in participating
So please go and scan the QR code
to find out more information on that
Now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and productivity
Now we enter the kingdom of silence
stillness and grace
Now we enter sacred space
We gather together to worship our loving, nurturing God
who like a mother
knows us intimately
loves us unconditionally
teaches us the way we should go
and comforts us in times of need
Praise God, the source and sustainer of life
May love find you, find us
May we all come home
Thank you Kat
If you guys want to stand with us
we're going to start with King of My Heart tonight
You guys sing out
I dare you to sing as loud as Finley
Let the king of my heart
Be the mountain where I run
The fountain I drink from
Oh, he is my song
Let the king of my heart
Be the shadow where I hide
The ransom for my life
Oh, he is my song
You are good, you're good
Oh, you are good, you're good
Let the king of my heart
Be the wind inside my sails
The anchor in my waves
Oh, he is my song
Let the king of my heart
Be the fire inside my veins
The echo of my days
Oh, he is my song
Let's sing that again
Let the king of my heart
Be the wind inside my sails
The anchor in my waves
Oh, he is my song
Let the king of my heart
Be the fire inside my veins
The echo of my days
Oh, he is my song
You are good, you're good
Oh, you are good, you're good
You're never gonna give
You're never gonna let me down
You're never gonna let
You're good, you're good
Oh, you are good, you're good
Oh
You're never gonna let
You're never gonna let me down
You are good
Thank you guys
It's so beautiful
Say hello
Okay, alright, thank you
Awesome
Alright, thank you kiddos
And thank you moms
Everyone out there who loves on people
Whether they are your own children or other children
That you love on
We're so so grateful for your impact in their life
And tonight in honors of Mother's Day
Instead of our typical prayers of the people
I wanted to wrap us up with
I mean, I wanted to go ahead and share a reading
I did not write this but it is one that continues
To touch my heart as we all have different
Seasons and different journeys that we find ourselves in
Especially as women on this day
It's a tribute to women on Mother's Day
To those who gave birth this year to their first child
We celebrate with you
To those who are in the trenches with little ones everyday
And wear the badge of food stains
We appreciate you
To those who experienced loss
Through miscarriage, failed adoptions, running away
Or the loss of a child
We mourn with you
To those who walk the hard path of infertility
Fraught with pokes, prods, tears and disappointment
We walk with you
Forgive us when we say foolish things
We don't mean to make things harder than they already are
To those who are foster moms, mentor moms
And spiritual moms
We need you
To those who have warm and close relationships with your children
We celebrate with you
And to those who have disappointment, heartache and dissents with your children
We sit with you
To those who have lost their mother this year
We grieve with you
To those who experienced abuse at the hands of your own mother
We acknowledge your experience
To those who lived through driving tests, medical tests
And overall testing of motherhood
We are better for having you in our midst
To those who are single
And long to be married and mothering your own children
We mourn that life has not turned out the way you longed for it to be
To those who step-parent
We walk with you on these complex paths
To those who envisioned lavishing love on grandchildren
Yet that dream is not to be
We grieve with you
To those who will have emptier nests in the coming year
We grieve and rejoice with you
To those who place children up for adoption
We commend you for your selflessness
And remember how you hold that child forever in your heart
To those who are pregnant with new life
Expected or surprising
We anticipate with you
This Mother's Day
We walk with you
Because mothering is not for the faint of heart
And we have real warriors in our midst
Today, we remember you
As I rise
Strength of God
Go before
Lift me up
As I wake
Eyes of God
Look upon
Be my sight
As I wake
Heart of God
Satisfied
And sustained
As I hear
The voice of God
Lead me on
Be my guide
Above and below me
Before and behind me
In every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
Above and below me
Before and behind me
In every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
As I go
Hand of God
My defense
By my side
As I rest
Breath of God
Fall upon
Bring me peace
Above and below me
Before and behind me
In every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
Above and below me
Before and behind me
In every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
Your life, your death
Your blood was shed
For every moment
Every moment
Your life, your death
Your blood was shed
For every moment
Every moment
Your life, your death
Your blood was shed
For every moment
Every moment
Your life, your death
Your blood was shed
For every moment
Every moment
Above and below me
Before and behind me
In every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
Above and below me
Before and behind me
In every eye that sees me
Christ be all around me
Oh, oh, oh
¶¶
The love of God
Is greater power
Than tongue or pen
Can ever tell
It goes beyond
The highest star
And reaches to
The lowest hell
The guilty path
Bow down with care
God gave his Son
To end
His erring child
He reconciled
And pardoned
His sin
¶¶
Oh, love of God
How rich and poor
How measureless
And strong
He shall forevermore endure
¶¶
When years of time
Shall pass away
And earthly thrones
And kingdoms fall
When men who hear
Refuse to pray
On rocks and hills
And mountains cold
God's love so sure
Shall still endure
Oh, measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
¶¶
Could we within
The oceans fail
And where the skies
Of parchment made
Were every stalk
On earth a quill
And every one
Ascribed by trade
To write the love
Of God above
Would drain the ocean dry
Nor could the scroll
Contain the whole
Though stretched from sky
To sky
Oh, love of God
How rich and pure
How measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
Oh, love of God
How rich and pure
How measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
¶¶
Yes, God, thank you that your love is so endless.
So forgiving.
So dependable.
That we can trust in it.
We can stand on it.
Thank you that it carries us through
The good seasons and the bad
The best days and the worst
That it never gives up on us
The Bible says that you gather us under your wings
Like chicks
That you bring us back from all corners of the earth
God, would you bring us back home
In the areas where we are lost
Where we have lost our way, God
Would we find you, Mother God
Gathering us together
Holding us close
Speaking life and love over us
It's in your name that we pray. Amen.
All right, can you guys turn and pass the peace to one another?
Well, grace and peace and welcome.
Welcome to the table.
Happy Mother's Day yet again to all you mamas out there.
And yeah, it's good to be together.
And also a warm welcome to those joining us online.
Don't forget your communion elements for later in the service.
And yeah, it's just a joy.
A joy to be with you, you all.
So, let's see.
This is week two, or kind of part two in our series.
We obviously had a week in between in our series titled
Enchanted, Reclaiming Sacred Ground in a Disenchanted World.
And so, this is, so kind of our big idea for this series
is basically that we, you know, we live in a, in kind of a secular age.
Of course it depends, it varies if you're, which region of the country you're in
and city versus rural, and you know, all that can influence
exactly to what degree you feel that, even like, do you go on to college
and so, you know, can you kind of feel some of this secularity
more so than in other spaces and places.
But, by and large though, the culture in a lot of ways
has kind of moved away from the, we might call kind of religion,
from the transcendent, and really has, to kind of use the post-modernist term,
has deconstructed religion and really kind of any metanarrative and such.
And, you know, and a lot of it for a good reason, you know,
just to kind of name that, like often religion had it coming.
Though not always, you know.
And it's interesting though, no matter how much we've tried
to kind of keep the transcendent out or, you know, kind of like edge it out,
oh boy, keep sneaking in, keep sneaking in, you know,
through the back door, so to speak.
And I would say, you know, thank God it does,
because I think it's really what makes life like worth living in a lot of ways,
which we'll get into more in the series.
I think a lot of the problem with a secular age,
this is something that Charles Taylor in his big old tome
called A Secular Age.
Oh man, it's a big one.
But he outlines where kind of it's in ways,
it's kind of drained a lot of the meaning out of things,
which we'll get to more in kind of future messages.
For example, we'll talk about sexuality is next week.
Not so much LGBTQ specifically, I just mean really sex in general.
And that's an area where you see the kind of a disenchanted frame of mind
as opposed to that topic, you know, for example.
So, yeah, so kind of what we're doing in the series
is kind of re-infusing some of these topics and things.
I think in ways that this sermon, as I've kind of reflected on it,
a lot of sermons are weird in that I often don't know what I'm writing
until the end, you know, and I never title a message until the end,
because I would always try, like, okay, so this is what I'm doing.
And then that's not what I do, you know what I mean?
I just end up changing anyway, so I always just do underscore, underscore.
So I write, the title of my message this week is underscore, underscore, underscore.
I have no idea. We'll see as we get to the end.
So, and really even as I edit it and kept working with it,
I've just been pondering, like, what is this exactly?
Because a lot of the future weeks I'll be getting into kind of more specific things,
you know, like I said, like sexuality or possibly I might do something on work.
And maybe even, I don't know, I might go back to the body,
like I mentioned two weeks ago, kind of the human body, how we view that.
Anyway, there's like lots of, almost anything, I mean, any topic.
The arts would be a huge, oh, I definitely need to get to that one.
You know, where, yeah, so those are specific topics.
This, though, I think I'm, what I'm kind of getting at a little bit in this specific message,
which, by the way, is titled, I found out later, truth in the superhuman.
I think this, I think today's kind of coming at this idea of truth
and, but really kind of contending that all truth is inherently religious truth, so to speak.
Even if you try to get away from that, you can't.
I think that's kind of what I'm kind of getting at.
So just hold that in your mind as we kind of go through this.
So our passage today is John chapter 14, verses 4 through 6,
where Jesus said, and you know the way to the place where I am going.
And Thomas said to him, Lord, we do not know where you are going.
How can we know the way?
And Jesus said to him, I am the way, and the truth, and the life.
So here's kind of my big idea for this sermon.
The truth is that which brings us into alignment.
Do I need to switch over to handheld?
Would that be better?
Give you?
Okay.
We believe.
The Ports tech team had a lot of challenges today.
It was one of those days, you know what I mean?
So, one of those days.
Okay, so here's kind of the big idea.
The truth is that which brings us into alignment
with the nature of reality itself.
And the way we conceive of reality is inevitably through a very big story.
A story which goes all the way to the roots of things
and tells us who we are and why we're here.
What is right and what is wrong and how we ought to live.
Now, there is much to hack a lot of people off in that definition.
Which we'll kind of get into.
That's what makes the sermon fun, you know what I mean?
You got to like, okay, why does this matter so much?
So, I think, so the first group of people I have in mind is,
so I was homeschooled from like, what, 4th?
4th through kind of 8th grade.
So, I'm familiar with that like, wing,
specifically kind of the evangelical homeschool movement.
And there was a lot of interest in kind of truth.
You know, the truthiness of truth.
And what is truth? And how do we know?
And you know, all that.
And yeah, that, so I would say that movement is right.
In the sense that capital T truth, so to speak,
has been under attack for the last 50 years or so.
What do I mean by capital T truth?
I'm thinking of, sort of like, it came into the world
with the kind of modern age,
with kind of the rise of science and such, you know?
This kind of idea of like, hey, I am just giving you the truth.
So, even, you can see where this even influenced the church.
Like, in this idea of, you know, with scripture and such,
where we start to relate to it as kind of just,
I'm just giving you the objective truth.
Right? I'm not interpreting.
I'm just giving you the truth.
And there's kind of something very modern about that.
In the sense of, hey, I, as a kind of objective,
uninfluenced, at least not much at all, really, kind of person,
I'm just going to now offer truth.
I'm just going to distill the truth using logic and reason and all of that.
So, this is where I would say kind of modern,
a lot of modern Christian thought and atheism, interestingly,
both have the same, what's called epistemology,
the same approach to truth,
where you're kind of using this pure reason and such.
So, here's the thing.
That idea has come under attack, and I agree with the attack.
That's where I hack off the people from my roots.
Oh, now you've thrown out truth.
Well, here's the trick.
This would really be the postmodernist, basically, critique.
They would say, well, look, here's the thing.
No one is unbiased.
No one is some blank slate of pure reason.
No one is some emotionless, pure thinker spouting truths.
Or to apply it in kind of a Christian context,
no one is, again, a kind of blank slate,
interpreting the scriptures and just offering them,
you know, just the truth of them to you.
All preaching, for example,
all scripture reading is interpretation.
What else can you do but you have the words
and you interpret the meaning of the words
as they are in the sentence.
You know what I mean?
But people's interpretations differ and such.
Why?
Because we're always coming from some perspective.
We've always already been influenced
by some received take on things.
We are always guided and nudged in ways
we both are and are not even aware of.
This would be like one of the great
kind of quote unquote masters of suspicion.
The group that really shifted this view on truth
and really the modern world in a lot of ways
is Nietzsche, Freud, and Marx.
Freud, in particular, because of the idea
of the unconscious.
Once you really acknowledge the unconscious in you,
it deeply undermines this approach to truth.
Because if you're like,
hey, I know what's influenced me.
No, you don't.
No, you're pushed and pulled and tugged.
You know what I mean?
For example, just the fact that someone's been a Christian
for like 50 years, there's a momentum there.
You know what I mean?
It's hard to just like, I'm just going to change
and believe this because that's the truth now.
No, there's all sorts of influences
and voices from the past.
And again, ones we're conscious of.
I know my Sunday school teachers from like 40 years ago
influenced me.
But also, they influenced me in ways I don't even know.
I'm not even aware.
I couldn't even give voice to it.
And yet, it's doing things to me.
It's true just for all sorts of stuff in the world.
The way theologian Graham Ward
kind of seconded this postmodern critique,
which he also agrees with.
He puts it like this.
He says, our certainties are persuasions.
Our facts are selections from the data available.
That's a really good insight.
Any fact, well, that's just a fact.
It's like, in the end, you've surveyed the world.
You've done your best to kind of distill,
but you've even chosen to focus here
and not there or not there or not there.
You know what I mean?
Like, in the end, you can't get away from it.
Our facts are selections from the data available.
Even our dogmatisms speak often more about our fears
than our aspirations.
That's a good insight.
That's some of that unconscious, too.
I mean, talk about fear influencing anyone
in ways we don't even understand.
All of us, right?
It's not just about those people out there.
Oh, can you believe those people?
No, no, this is all of us.
We're all kind of trapped in this, you know.
Okay, so, that was a big old sigh.
Now, I think much of modern culture
has sort of taken on this critique, right?
So, I think a lot of, even a lot of people in this room
might not be offended by much of what I just said,
you know, in terms of like, yeah, yeah, it makes,
I can see that, it makes a lot of sense, you know?
And, I mean, in ways, even the,
I would say the kind of more progressive liberal spirit
is mostly down for this critique, you know?
So, for example, the notions of tolerance
and, you know, a kind of openness.
Like, yeah, there's something good there.
Or even a kind of openness like, hey,
okay, so we take this capital T truth
that's kind of been chopped down to lowercase t truths.
So, now it's sort of like, well, there's just truths.
You know what I mean?
Just truths, and not the truth,
like this is the truth, you better believe it, you know,
but it's just truths, you have your truth,
and I have my truth, and we're, you know,
we're kind of doing our best here.
So, what's the kind of challenge to this?
Well, this leads to what Alistair MacIntyre,
he calls it emotivism.
The view that moral judgments are mere expressions
of approval or disapproval,
not whether they are true or false.
This would be the challenge, like,
if you're kind of like, yeah,
I'm done with that other view of truth,
you know, now I'm just embracing this one.
This would be the kind of Achilles heel
of this perspective, right?
Because this goes fine,
especially for stuff that doesn't really matter,
like, oh, you have your opinions, I have mine, whatever,
you know, live and let live, it's cool.
But until we bump up against things where it's like,
oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
well, this really matters.
This is a belief.
This is a story or whatever,
like, I think this really matters,
and suddenly we're having conflict with one another.
It could be across cultures,
or it could be even, you know, within a culture,
within a church, you know.
Even, like, the broader church,
you see a lot of this happening right now.
So suddenly, right, all we kind of have
is the language of emotions, you know,
so not, hey, that's wrong,
but I disapprove.
That would be Alistair MacIntyre's critique.
By the way, if you want more on this,
some of you are like,
no, this is not my kind of stuff.
But for those of you who are, like,
nerding out with me, sorry,
this whole sermon, it doesn't get any better.
It's, like, super nerdy,
and it's just, this is what it is.
After Virtue is his book
where he goes into a lot of this.
It's a brilliant, huge influence
on theology and philosophy in the modern world,
like, huge.
So in essence, what he named,
he really does a good job of naming,
I mean, if you just look at the culture after this,
because basically you'll start to realize
that because we don't have
a shared kind of tradition anymore,
and even a kind of shared tradition
of, like, virtue and what's right and what's wrong,
once that breaks down,
all you really have now, in ways,
is emotivism.
So there's a lot, and basically,
so the way to win is to ramp it up.
This leads to what I'll call megaphone politics, right?
And it can be other, not just politics,
but it can be all sorts of things,
but it's sort of, you know,
whoever can yell louder wins.
And that's kind of where we are, right?
This is kind of the state
of our social and political discourse right now,
because these objective notions of truth and such,
we've kind of, we don't really trust those
to do the heavy lifting anymore.
We don't really know if we can really convince people
with, you know, those arguments anymore.
And so now we kind of devolve
into just subjective personal attitudes, right?
Even, again, and even in the church,
where we're kind of just lobbying emotional grenades
across the aisle at one another,
you know what I mean?
There's not really, like, serious dialogue.
There is in maybe some academic circles,
but, like, not generally.
I mean, for example, whatever you see online
isn't like, oh, wow, some really deep digging here.
You know, generally it's emotional grenades,
and this is what we're doing.
Okay, so what's the way forward?
Well, I want to invite you to, again,
kind of reflect on my opening big idea.
The truth is that which brings us into alignment
with the nature of reality itself,
and the way we conceive of reality
is inevitably through a very big story.
A story which goes all the way to the roots of things
and tells us who we are and why we're here
and what is right and what is wrong
and how we ought to live.
Now, what I want to contend is
what we can call this, what I mean by
very big story is a religious tradition.
Now, this is, on this point,
even the atheist Yuval Harari,
anyone read his book, Sapiens?
And a really, really good,
it was like a runaway bestseller like 10 years ago.
So he is, kind of has more Jewish roots,
but atheist, not into religion, all that stuff.
However, he defined a religious system this way.
He said, religion is a system of human norms and values
that is founded on belief in a superhuman order.
Now, the key word there is superhuman.
He means here, something beyond the human.
So, for example, Harari would say,
it's not just like, you know,
Christianity or Islam or some other,
oh, that's a religious tradition.
Yeah, we know that because they believe in like the superhuman,
that which is, you know, God and such.
Now, for example, Harari says,
Marxist ideology is a religious tradition.
Why? Because there's an appeal to a superhuman order,
that which is above, that which is beyond the human.
So, for example, good Marxists,
you know, they believe in the,
often it's capital letters that give it away
in philosophers' writings, you know.
All of a sudden, it's like, it's capitalized
because there's something big here.
You know what I mean?
Verses of historical materialism, right?
Which doesn't mean anything to you
because you're, I don't know,
maybe some of you are Marxists, I don't know.
But for them, that's just like,
yes, now we're talking, right?
Or class struggle or inevitable progress, right?
So, to really be a true Marxist,
or sorry, I should say, to a true Marxist,
if you're a capitalist,
you're not just someone with a different opinion,
my friend, you're wrong, right?
And you're wrong because you're opposing the superhuman, right?
That which is above and beyond us,
the inevitable force of this history or, you know, whatever.
And, of course, don't you dare question
our sacred scriptures,
Communist Manifesto and so on and so forth.
Like, every tradition kind of has its things, right?
Its patron saints and all of that.
Capitalism also, according to Harari,
a religious tradition, right?
There's a collective belief and faith in the future,
in the great forces of the market, right?
The invisible hand shall move.
It's quite a mystical kind of image,
even, that Adam Smith gave there.
Right?
The invisible hand shall move.
And by all of us kind of pursuing
our own individual self-interest,
what will happen?
Well, by faith, you know,
we trust that even though we individually are pursuing
our own self-interest,
only the good, a greater good,
sort of GDP without end, you know,
will increase.
And how do we know this?
We don't know this, like, for sure.
It seems, you know, we can have our history and say,
well, up to this point, it seems to be working, you know,
but is there any guarantee?
Well, you know, but we trust.
We have faith.
I mean, again, kind of going back to that definition,
if you think of this as like, you know,
capitalism, again, as a very big story, right?
It goes all the way to the roots of things,
who you are and why you're here
and what's right and wrong, right?
And you can see where it's a kind of meta-narrative.
It's a big story that we all kind of collectively
sort of buy into.
I mean, this is where the insanity of,
if you ever thought about, why money?
Like, why does money even work?
And the truth is, it's just a story.
It's just trust.
I mean, it literally, it's just
because we all think it matters.
That's it.
You know what I mean?
Like, you just, and if we stop believing, it dies.
You know, so there's a lot of faith,
you know, kind of going on here.
I think even of another patron saint
other than Adam Smith would be Ayn Rand.
Her novel, Atlas Shrugged,
with its kind of a libertarian
kind of ethics and such, right?
That's a really, that's a perfect expression
of almost the religious fervor,
not almost, the literal religious fervor
of capitalism, right?
Where again, it becomes not just sort of
a certain theory of how something,
but it's a kind of grand narrative
that you live into,
that you buy into,
and it guides who you are
and who you ought to be,
and you know, all that.
Even evolutionary theory
can kind of go from this sort of
a scientific theory describing what is,
which I want to be clear,
I don't think like,
oh, science is just religion.
No, no.
When religion, when science
is just describing what is,
well, that's just what science does.
It kind of categorizes out
all the other stuff,
any sort of things it can't measure or see,
you know, it's just like,
okay, that's how it operates.
The trick is,
suddenly in the minds and the mouths
and the writings of some,
it can morph into a superhuman order,
a religious tradition.
When it goes right from, again,
describing what is,
certain biological principles
around survival of the fittest
and all that,
to suddenly a grand story
touching on ethics and economics
and even can start to describe
a kind of utopian super race
that we all,
not just might evolve into,
but we are called to live into.
It's just, it's just science and biology
and you must, you know,
and it's kind of like,
we just changed something.
We just, what happened?
Now it's not just, you know,
kind of evolutionary theory, the sign.
Now it's the grand meta-narrative
evolutionary theory.
Oh, now we're, you know,
buckle up for that kind of world.
I mean, infamously,
Nazism loved,
incorporated evolutionary theory
into its story.
It was like, yes,
we can work with this, right?
It opposed the Western liberal
religious tradition
with its, you know,
it would say kind of mythical,
the equality of all people,
the rights, we all have rights,
don't we?
You know, it's religious tradition, right?
Western liberalism is its own kind of,
and then they oppose that
and they're like,
that is stupid and foolish.
We all know, just look at the world.
People are not equal, right?
And they oppose that narrative
and said, we all know
that certain people,
the Aryan people,
they're the pinnacle
of what evolution and science are doing
and so what we all must,
don't, you can't oppose
the march of history.
You know, I mean,
you can see where this takes on.
It's religious tradition.
Now, many of you know,
I went through a season
of deconstruction many years ago.
I was a hard,
this is where I go more Christianity
for those of you who are just like,
oh my God,
it's just a college lecture, you know?
I was a hard-nosed skeptic, you know?
And at that time,
I was leaning pretty,
I was leaning towards becoming an atheist.
I don't think I was quite there,
kind of that, no,
I was going to say no man's land,
maybe that's, we don't say it anymore,
I don't know,
maybe it's no person's land,
doesn't have quite the same ring,
but you know,
I was in kind of no person's land
agnosticism, you know?
And just kind of,
but I was flirting, you know?
I was like,
and it was because
I just didn't want to be taken in again.
You know,
I'd kind of,
leaving that Christian faith,
deconstructing that Christian faith
because I could tell,
it's a story, it's a story,
you know what I mean?
And I was kind of,
so I'm going to leave that
and I just didn't want to be taken in again
by any sort of stupid theological ideas
just because they sounded nice.
You know,
I wanted the truth.
But all of what I just talked about
is what I started bumping into.
I started realizing,
dang it,
I can always cast a skeptical eye
towards any story.
Right?
In other words,
the minute I finish deconstructing
my Christian story,
well, and by the way,
many don't seem to, right?
They will do that,
kind of deconstruct,
and I think there can be goodness in that,
you know?
But we kind of,
or it can be real hard on Christian faith
and then very naive
about the religious tradition we go to next.
You know,
you're just sort of like,
yes, whatever,
because we don't even think of it
as a religious tradition,
you know what I mean?
That needs to be deconstructed.
But I guess I had read enough
at that point that I knew,
well, no, no, no,
I need to do the same thing
with these other stories,
but that was the problem.
I just moved on
to deconstructing the next grand narrative
and then the next
and the next
and it turns out
it's tradition all the way down.
It's story,
it's, what is that old saying
about turtles all the way down?
It's, you know,
it's tradition,
it's story all the way down.
Western liberalism,
libertarian capitalism,
Marxism, Buddhism,
hardcore atheist materialism,
story, story, story.
So then I said,
okay, oh, okay, okay, okay,
maybe, maybe I can just like
do away with any and all story.
Have you considered this?
Well, I certainly did.
Like, maybe I am,
I'm just, I'm the person
who has no story.
That is my story.
My story is that I have no story.
I am no one,
coming from nowhere,
headed towards absolutely nothing.
Well, that of course
is called nihilism,
meaninglessness.
It's what's left at the end
of the postmodern
kind of deconstructionist road
when you've just deconstructed
the hell out of everything.
Yes, bastard just cursed,
but for emphasis,
you know, like,
just, it's just,
this is a mess, right?
We just kind of deconstruct
and then that's,
you can offer that.
Now here's the trick.
Even if I,
this is what I also realized,
even if intellectually I said,
okay, okay, I am brave,
I am brave, I can do this.
I'm doing, this is my story,
I have no story,
it's all just foolishness
and, you know what I mean,
meta-narratives are so dumb
and I'm not abiding
into any of that crap,
you know, okay, okay,
here I am.
The problem is,
I have to live.
I have to,
I actually have to like,
act in the world.
I have to do things, right?
And so I could say,
intellectually,
yeah, story's stupid,
you know what I mean?
But then,
I had to like,
do the,
and what was guiding
my actions?
What was moving me
towards this and not that?
And well,
if I was really honest,
there's certain values
happening there, right?
There's a kind of
hierarchy of values
and I have like,
certain values
towards the top
and I'm like,
prioritizing those values.
Why?
Why those values
and not other values?
Well,
because secretly,
I'm drawing
from a grand story.
So, you know,
one of the ones on offer
that I find kind of beautiful
or compelling
or, you know,
I can't help it.
And,
so I kind of realized,
like, okay,
well,
rather than like,
freaking out
at the unprovable-ness
of it all,
rather than gnashing my teeth
about the uncertainty
of it all,
I said, okay,
well,
what are those values?
What are those values
deep, deep, deep, deep,
deep within me?
And,
and what religious tradition
or traditions
are giving rise to those?
What's,
what's going on there,
Brett?
And,
this is when I realized
I was much more of a Christian
than I ever maybe
even wanted to admit.
You know,
even as I was
leaving Christianity,
oh, that's so dumb,
but I just,
you know,
I've been so powerfully
shaped by
that whole story
that I totally am,
I'm a total sucker
for like,
rising up
the weak
and the marginalized
and,
you know what I mean?
The voiceless,
let's give them a voice
and that's like,
that's just Christian,
you know what I mean?
Like, I can be like,
oh, no, no, no,
I'm just,
but I am,
I was,
I realized it was just like,
in me.
And,
I do,
I find this,
I really find
the Christian kind of tradition,
the story,
is at its best,
because of course,
there's wings of the church
and theologies and such
that I just find
downright repulsive,
let's be clear, you know?
So it's not as easy
as just,
oh, I'm a Christian,
you know,
but there's aspects of it
that I,
I just find that,
I think it's one of the most
powerful,
beautiful,
compelling stories
because it says that
at the heart of all things
is love.
And,
it says that you
and me
and all creation
were brought into existence
by the God who is love.
And we know that God is love
not only because of Jesus,
of course,
who reveals that,
but because God,
in her very being,
God is Trinity.
God is Father or Mother
or Son, Spirit.
God is loving relationality.
And even,
even though the world has fallen
and humans are prone
to every sort of mess,
I mean, just look at the news,
you know,
God didn't give up on us.
God didn't condemn us
to everlasting torment.
God slipped into the skin
of the person of Jesus Christ
and taught us the way
of great love.
A great love that extends
not just to our in-group
or those we naturally love
like our partner
or our family,
can't get that in evolutionary theory
as a meta-narrative,
as a story,
you know what I mean,
but even extends out
all the way
even to our enemies.
And then Christ died on the cross
to show us
that he's the type of God
who would rather die than kill.
And now his life, an example,
forms the very basis
for my life.
And now my highest aim,
my goal,
my telos,
my purpose
is to be one with this God
who is love.
And then everything flows
from there.
Everything,
my views on prayer,
my views on politics,
my economics,
my views on everything
from sexuality,
to family,
to war,
to empathy,
it's all informed
or at least it should be informed,
it's an ongoing project, you know,
by this Trinitarian
Christ-like love
and grace.
And so I believe that to say,
as our opening scripture did,
that Jesus is the way,
Jesus is the truth,
you know, he's the life.
As a Christian,
really is to say,
this is who Jesus Christ is.
His is the story of great love.
And so by God's grace,
through the Holy Spirit,
I long to bring myself
more and more and more deeply
into alignment with his ways,
with that love.
And this is why I said,
the truth is that which brings us
into alignment with the nature
of reality itself.
And the way we conceive of reality
is inevitably, inescapably,
as a very big story,
a story which goes all the way
to the roots of things
and tells us who we are
and why we're here,
what is right, what is wrong,
and how we ought to live.
So if you believe
that the highest human,
or the highest value
for human flourishing
is material wealth and prosperity,
that's your religious tradition,
and you will orient your life
and your family's life
and those around you,
you'll try to influence them,
towards that vision of the good.
And if you believe
that the nature of reality
is a machine,
then you'll orient your life,
yourself, and your world to that.
And if you believe
the nature of reality is love,
well then, you'll orient yourself,
your life,
the lives of those around you,
to that.
So just to kind of summarize,
I know this has been a lot,
a few little implications
that'll be close.
Number one,
truth is always grounded
in some broader tradition
of human thought and living.
So we're always,
kind of can't get away from that.
We're always drawing
from some religious tradition here.
Second,
you're never speaking
to a religion-less
or a tradition-less person.
In other words,
all of us,
we all draw from
some transcendent,
superhuman order
to guide our lives,
whether it's Stoicism,
which is actually
making a comeback.
Honestly, you know why?
It's because people
can't really live
with that secular,
that disenchanted world,
that meaningless,
you can't do it.
And so these beliefs,
they just kind of cycle back.
Stoicism!
Sexy!
My guess is,
honestly,
actually this has happened
in history,
my guess is Christianity
might be making a comeback,
which is weird to think.
But through,
yeah,
once Stoicism is like,
it's like the first step
towards embracing
more other bigger
religious traditions.
But whether it's Stoicism,
Nationalism,
Capitalism,
Atheism,
whatever,
people are always living that.
Third,
we should not be embarrassed
to embrace a religious tradition.
Like some purely religionless,
rich religionless person.
Yeah,
and I think Christians
need to remember that.
Because we often feel,
I don't know about you,
but it was easy in my
kind of deconstruction days
to feel very like,
I'm the weird one here,
I'm like believing
in superhuman orders,
and you know,
like I don't know,
just stepping out into faith
like an idiot,
you know what I mean?
As opposed to realizing
everyone's doing it,
everyone's playing the game,
you know what I mean?
Like everyone's gotta like,
I don't know,
but I gotta live,
and something's guiding me here,
so here we go,
buckle up,
you know what I mean?
And that all of a sudden,
I'm much more chill now
when I talk with almost anyone,
you know what I mean?
Because I'm always just curious,
like what are you?
You know what I mean?
Like I'm really interested,
like I'm wondering
what their crazy beliefs,
you know what I mean?
I got my crazy beliefs,
you know,
that's fine.
But I'm just,
you know,
it's more curious
rather than kind of like,
I know I'm stupid,
you know.
Fourth,
traditions are not
totally distinct entities.
Throughout human history,
they arise from,
they mingle with,
they influence one another.
This is something that,
it could be a weakness
of the sermon,
for simplicity's sake,
I just kept talking about
tradition,
and that tradition,
and that one,
you know,
but the truth is,
you can break those down.
And it's not like
there are these monolithic
distinct things,
like from the beginning
of time,
or from its early days,
Christianity was talking
with,
obviously,
Judaism,
for example,
that's a big influence,
you know,
like clearly.
And even since then,
since then,
Stoicism,
and later,
Aristotle had huge influence
on Christian,
and Platonism,
and by the way,
some people often try
to then recover,
and there's a debate
that can happen like,
no,
we shouldn't have mingled
with that tradition,
and we shouldn't have,
you know,
and that's fine,
but I actually think it was,
I think Christianity's better
from having mingled with
Aristotle,
with Plato,
with some others.
Other Christians would disagree,
but yeah,
that's okay, right?
So there's,
this happens,
and that's fine.
Fifth though,
when seen from the eyes
I think this is clear,
or I want to make this clear,
in other words,
some are closer
to the vision of God
as love than others,
because one takeaway
could be like,
oh,
so there's just like
different religious traditions,
and they're like all cool.
I'm like,
no,
I mean,
hopefully you picked up
from what I was hinting at,
like,
no,
I think,
like I'm real concerned
about evolutionary theory,
not as a scientific theory,
I like totally accept that,
but as a meta-narrative,
I am out hardcore on that.
I think it's awful.
Like,
oh yeah,
everyone's got their tradition,
that's cool,
you know,
like,
no,
it's not all cool,
we gotta,
there's cross-cultural,
cross-tradition talk
that has to happen,
and negotiation,
and sometimes really tough critiques,
you know,
and that's good.
Sixth and finally,
speaking of one monolithic tradition
for each of these religious movements
isn't totally fair,
they're nuanced living things,
right?
So,
for example,
like saying,
Christianity,
you know,
there's Christianities,
and there's different wings,
and,
and the same for,
people often just with,
or realize that nuance
about their own tradition,
not for others,
right?
So,
they're just sort of like,
sort of clunkily,
you know,
like,
well,
Islam is this,
you know,
and it's like real clunky,
because if you're in that tradition,
you actually know,
well,
there's like a lot of approaches
on this thing,
you know what I mean?
And so,
it's good to be aware of that
as we go into the world,
that we're not just kind of clunkily,
yeah,
critiquing others,
or,
and even being more aware
of what we're drawing from,
in our own kind of tradition.
So,
yeah,
so I think to kind of leave you
with a little metaphor,
I think in the end,
what I'm kind of wanting
is for all of us to,
to kind of have the freedom
to just be rooted
where God's inviting us to root,
and,
and to encourage you,
like,
the Christian tradition
in Christ,
it is a big,
and be,
and be a beautiful,
and be a big,
tradition,
and I know just the nature
of our community,
we have all the critiques,
and all the question marks of church,
and,
you know,
all the stuff,
and there,
and that's,
a lot of it's warranted,
but,
boy,
there's so much goodness
and beauty
here,
that I think the world,
honestly,
really,
really needs,
and so I just,
I think I just wanna encourage you
and like I mentioned
a few weeks ago,
even if that,
just cause of past trauma
and such,
that can't be here,
or be in this tradition,
my goodness,
find a,
a beautiful one then,
and,
yeah,
be rude,
in the name of the Father,
the Son,
and the Holy Spirit,
amen.
Amen.
Woo,
that was a long one,
that was like,
I don't even know what that,
was that even a sermon?
I'm not sure.
Unclear.
Yeah.
Well,
on the night Jesus was betrayed,
he had one final meal
with his disciples,
and at that meal,
he held up a loaf of bread,
and he broke it,
and he said,
take it and eat,
this is my body,
it's broken for you,
and then he held up
a cup of wine,
he said,
this is my blood,
it's shed for you,
whenever you eat this bread,
whenever you drink this cup,
remember me,
and so as we come forward,
that's what we're doing,
we're participating together
to re-center on Christ,
on the God who is love,
and be formed
in that tradition ourselves.
So, yeah,
we practice an open table,
so everyone's
welcome to participate,
we'll just go row by row,
and yeah, yeah,
y'all partake whenever,
however you'd like.
So, this is the table,
not of the church,
but of the Lord,
and it's made ready
for those who love him,
and for those who want
to love him more,
so come.
You who have much faith,
and you who have little,
you who have been here often,
and you who have not
been here long,
you who have tried to follow,
and you who have failed,
come.
Come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you,
and it's his will
that those who want to meet him
should meet him here.
Come to the table.
Come.
If you guys want to stand with us,
we're going to close out
with that last verse
of the love of God,
which to me is just the inspiration
of this gospel message
and this Jesus that we follow
is just the uncontainable,
uncondensable love of Jesus.
Could we with ink
The ocean fell
And where the skies
Of parchment made
Were every stalk
On earth a quill
And every one
A scribe by trade
To write the love
Of God above
Would drain the ocean dry
Nor could the scroll
Contain the whole
Though stretched from sky
To sky
The love of God
How rich and pure
How measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
Oh love of God
So rich and pure
How measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
Thank you so much
for joining us this evening.
If you are new,
we would love for you
to fill out a card at the table
on your way out
or just scan the QR code
and fill out an online visitor's card.
Generosity is a key aspect
of life, of adoration,
and worship.
To give financially,
you can scan the QR code
or visit thetabletx.org.
If you call the table home
but don't have a meetup,
we would love for you to explore.
Just go to the QR code
and look at the different meetups
and see if there might be something
that stands out to you.
In the community,
it's important to have a meetup.
So if you'd like to do that,
we would love for you to join us.
There are several to choose from.
Alright, I'm going to send you out
with a benediction.
Let me send you in this blessing.
You can hold out your hands
in a posture to receive
or just open your heart
to these words.
You are a child of God.
This is true on your best day
and it's true on your worst day.
So as you go into your week ahead
with its yet to be determined highs and lows
and everything in between,
go filled with the assurance
that you are loved.
You are worthy.
You are accepted
just as you are.
And go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend
these same gifts of grace
and unconditional love
to everyone you come in contact with.
Be blessed.
Have a good week.
And we hope to see you back here
next Sunday.
And Happy Mother's Day.
Good night.
♪
Oh love of God
So rich and pure
So measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
Oh love of God
So rich and pure
How measureless
And strong
It shall forevermore endure
The saints' and angels' song
♪
Hold on love
Things are gonna get better
I know it's hard
Hold on love
Things are gonna get better
I know they are
♪